[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos hablando de la
estación espacial internacional porque
tras más de 20 años de cooperación entre
eeuu y rusia bosco informó que se
retirara del proyecto en 2024 el anuncio
fue hecho por el nuevo jefe de la
agencia espacial rusa roscósmos jury
borísov la intención es que en ese
momento rusia empiece a construir su
propia estación orbital
y
cosmonautas rusos a bordo de la estación
espacial internacional una realidad
desde hace más de 20 años pero pronto la
imagen pertenecerá al pasado es lo que
anunció el nuevo jefe de la agencia
espacial rusa durante una conversación
con vladímir putin en el kremlin
sin duda cumpliremos todas nuestras
obligaciones con nuestros socios pero la
decisión de dejar la estación después de
2024 está tomada
la nasa asegura que no ha sido
notificada oficialmente de la retirada
de euros ya después de 2024
la estación espacial internacional es
una de las pocas cooperaciones que aún
existen entre moscú y washington en el
lado ruso ya se están preparando para el
futuro la nueva prioridad para el
programa espacial nacional una estación
orbital o rusa que podría parecerse a
esto
yo creo que para entonces empezaremos a
crear una estación orbital rusa azul
afectado por las fuertes sanciones
occidentales de los últimos meses y la
corrupción generalizada el sector
aerospacial ruso se encuentra según las
propias autoridades en una situación
difícil esto contrasta con china que
debería completar su propia estación
espacial a finales de año una hazaña
tecnológica lograda en menos de dos años
el final de esta cooperación se anuncia
en medio de la guerra en ucrania lo que
ha generado varias rondas de sanciones
internacionales contra rusia previamente
ya el kremlin había amenazado con
retirarse no obstante que esta decisión
llegue con el nuevo jefe de roscósmos y
se anunciada desde ya para 2024 hace
pensar que ahora sí se convertirá en
realidad en france 24 conversamos con
raúl joya olarte ingeniero mecánico con
especialización en astronomía que nos
explicó cómo esta retirada puede ser
considerada una pérdida a nivel
científico dentro del ámbito y trabajo
de lo que son astronautas y cosmonautas
existe una gran cordialidad y una
hermandad y trabajo en equipo los
equipos de ingeniería de ambos países y
de la estación espacial internacional
mencionando japón y europa todos ellos
siempre están trabajando y lógicamente
están siendo afectados por estos
estudios de índole político entonces si
es una gran pérdida para el desarrollo
de la investigación los mismos
todos los seres que están investigando
en esa estación espacial internacional
están perdiendo un gran aliado la
estación espacial internacional fue
diseñada para ser interdependiente esto
significa que los módulos
estadounidenses al menos por el momento
no pueden funcionar sin los rusos la
estación tiene un segmento ruso que se
encarga de los sistemas de propulsión y
un segmento estadounidense que se
encarga de la electricidad y los
sistemas de soporte vital por lo que hay
una clara interdependencia la
instalación está en la órbita baja pesa
unas 500 toneladas le da una vuelta a la
tierra cada 90 minutos y requiere una
propulsión determinada para mantenerse a
unos 400 kilómetros de altura esto
explica garde reisman eyes ex astronauta
de la nasa
en el lado ruso depende completamente
del lado de estadounidense para la
energía eléctrica el lado estadounidense
depende completamente del lado ruso para
la propulsión tanto para el control de
altitud como para las maniobras y para
de saturar nuestros giroscopios entonces
por esas razones no puedes tener un
divorcio amistoso va a ser feo y como
resultado estamos un poco bloqueados
juntos es por eso que ha sido el único
aspecto de la cooperación entre eeuu y
rusia que ha persistido a lo largo de
todas las tensiones actuales
ya desde hace varios años eeuu empezó a
desarrollar sus propias naves y cohetes
para enviar astronautas al espacio lo
que redujo su dependencia de rusia ahora
los expertos indican que tanto la nasa
como compañías privadas ya están
trabajando en encontrar formas de
mitigar el impacto de esta retirada en
2024 cuando todavía faltarán seis años
del período previsto para el
funcionamiento de la estación que va
hasta 2030
desde el punto district de ingeniería es
muy difícil reemplazar los módulos que
tiene rusia eso no se puede hacer de la
mezcla manera en hacer está mucho mucho
tiempo lo que seguramente va a ser el
consorcio de países ahorita es estudiar
la posibilidad de poner otro tipo de
máquinas y artefactos no tanto como
laboratorio sino como de sistemas de
propulsión porque esa estación necesita
mantenerse a cierta altura y
constantemente hacer correcciones de su
órbita entonces eso es lo que es de
pronto si da dos años le da tiempo para
este grupo de países conseguirlo además
del impacto para la investigación
científica hasta el impacto económico
pese a que tanto eeuu como rusia han
realizado avances importantes en
tecnología en la última década no todos
estos componentes ya se han puesto en
órbita
y si no va a ser fácil ni barato
reemplazar toda la capacidad rusa con
capacidad estadounidense en sólo dos
años pero sí creo que es posible creo
que es algo que deberíamos haber estado
haciendo desde el momento en que
cruzaron la frontera hacia ucrania creo
que deberíamos haberlo visto venirme y
creo que ha habido algún esfuerzo pero
de nuevo ha sido a un nivel bajo y entre
bastidores para evitar antagonizar con
los rusos e interrumpir esta asociación
pero creo que ahora es el momento de
hacerlo con prisa de aured to be with 6
expertos explican que esta retirada así
puede significar una pérdida tanto para
estados unidos como para rusia no
obstante también se trata de una valiosa
oportunidad de impulsar y acelerar los
desarrollos principalmente para moscú
que venía realizando una inversión menor
a la de hace décadas en ciencia y
tecnología esto será clave si realmente
materializan sus planes de una estación
orbital propia y también si en algún
punto deciden cooperar con china cuya
estación tiangong está sumamente
avanzada así llegamos al final de este
espacio les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france 24 y
france24 puntocom
y